Transcriber: Yiğit Mehmet Behrem
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Konuşmanın başlığı
″Siz hiç ilham perisi gördünüz mü?″
Biz o konuda çok şanslı
bir toplumuz, milletiz.
Biz ilham perisini sadece görmüyoruz
onu aynı zamanda yaşıyoruz,
onu hissediyoruz, onu hatta duyumsuyoruz.
Adeta bizim için kültürel bir
kod haline gelmiş durumda.
Şimdi sabahleyin bu konuşmayı yapacağımı
öğrenince Türkiye'nin böyle dünya çapında
önemli bir virtüözü , kanun virtüözü
Ahmet Baran bizim için bir 50 saniyelik
kayıt yapıp gönderdi.
Bir onu dinleyelim,
ilham perimizi görelim.
Evet aslında
dün bu saat itibariyle başka
bir şey konuşacaktım.
Konuşacağım konu kripto paraların
davranış bilimleriydi.
Kripto paraların teknik kısmıyla kim
kazandı, kim kaybetti çok ilgilenmiyorum
ama onun davranış bilimleri
gerçekten çok özgün bir konu.
Belki rapora denk gelmişsinizdir.
Dünya Ekonomik Formu’nun bu yılın başında
geçen seneye dair yayınladığı bir
rapor vardı.
Rapor enteresandı.
Türkiye kripto para sahipliği konusunda
dünyada dördüncü, Avrupa’da birinci.
Şimdi bizden önce kimler var diye
baktığınızda birinci sırada Nijerya var,
ikinci sırada Vietnam,
üçüncü sırada Filipinler var.
Eğer Nijerya, Filipinler ve Vietnam'ın
dünyada teknolojiyi en iyi kullanan ve
gelecek entegrasyonu en yüksek olan
ülkeleri olmadığını düşünüyorsak
ki düşünüyoruz tabi.
Demek ki orada başka bir
sosyolojik yönelim var.
Dolayısıyla burayı yorumlamak Türkiye
sosyolojisi hakkında da bize pek çok
veri verecektir
ama derken ne oldu?
İşte iki gün önce Samsun'daki Onur
Anıtı'na yapılan saldırıdan sonra ben
TEDx´deki bu 18 dakikalık hakkımı bu
konuşmadan yana kullanmak istedim
ve günümüzde en yakın görüntüleriyle,
gerçekten renklendirilmiş harika
görüntülerle de onu bir kez daha
arka tarafta yaşayalım istedim.
Konuşma boyunca bu ilerleyecek.
Aslında bakıldığında olayın kendisini
çok da önemli bulmadım.
Alışmasak iyi olur ama bir şeye
alıştık farkındaysanız.
Ülkede ne kadar bir karmaşa dönüyorsa,
işte arka tarafta zamlar, çeşitli siyasal
tartışmalar dönüyorsa, genelde çok
alıştığımız konu Atatürk’ün ya büstüne,
ya heykeline bir saldırı
gerçekleştirilir
ya da siyasilerden birinden böyle
irrasyonel bir demeç duyarız ve enteresan
bir hal alır bu durum.
Fakat bunun bir de başka bir tarafı var.
Acaba böyle bir şeyin
iyi bir sonucu olur mu ?
Bu bence iyi bir sonucu oluyor
ki şöyle bir şey oluyor.
Biz mesela iki gün boyunca Atatürk’ü
daha çok anlamaya, kendi duygularımızı,
sosyal medyadan veya özel konuşmalarımızı
daha çok ifade etmeye başladık.
Belki de tam tersi bir sonuç doğuruyordur
ama diğer taraftan işin biraz
bilgi felsefesine bakalım.
Bu da önemli.
Atatürk zaten çok özel bir akıl.
Sizce Atatürk’ün büstü, heykeli, biblosu,
posteri, afişi ne kadar Atatürk için
önemlidir ki?
Biz bu tür gerçekleştirilen olaylar
üzerine acaba ne kadar dertlenmeliyiz ?
Diye kendisine başvurayım, istedim
birkaç tane çözümü size tekrarlayacağım
bence önemli.
Ne diyor Atatürk diyor ki
büyük ölülerin diyor
matemlere ihtiyacı yoktur diyor.
Onların fikirlerinin anlaşılmasına
ihtiyacı vardır diyor
ya da bir başka çok iyi bildiğimiz
sözünde benim diyor
yüzümü göremeyebilirsiniz
ama beni hissettiğinizde beni
anladığınız da zaten amaç
hasıl olmuş olur diyor.
Zaten vakaya böyle bakan bir insanın
heykeline yapılan saygısızlık,
urgan bağlamak ya da ona pranga vurmaya
çalışmak gerçekten çok amaçsız bir...
durum gibi gerçekleşiyor ben bunu birkaç
tane kavram üzerinden sizle paylaşmak
paylaşmak istiyorum.
Çünkü benim temelde Atatürk öğretilerine
ilişkin on yıllardır yanlışlar
yaptığımızı düşünüyorum bunlar
semantik böyle anlamsal yanlışlar,
özellikle Atatürk pedagojisi yani
çocuklar ve gençler için Atatürk’ü
anlamada ve anlatmakta,
çok ciddi problemler çektiğimizi
düşünüyorum.
Atatürk’ü bizim algılayış biçimimiz
enteresan bir süper kahraman bir Marvel
karakteri gibi yenilmez, düşmez,
asla asla o süper kahraman
niteliklerinin dışında davranmaz.
Adeta onun muzaffer oluşu kendini
gerçekleştiren bir kehanet gibidir
gibi anlatırız.
Ama Atatürk aslında böyle bir adam değil.
Hayatın hepimiz çok iyi biliyoruz.
On yıllar boyunca aslında çaresizlikler
ile mücadele etmiş, pek çok kez yenilmiş
ve en muzaffer olduğu konuda aslında genç
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'ni kurmak olmuş bu
genç Türkiye Cumhuriyeti
eski ya da yeni değil.
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti ve ilelebet yaşayacak
olan Cumhuriyeti kurması aslında onun
muzaffer duruşunun en güzel ifadesi.
Bakın 7 yaşında yetim kalan, 8 yaşında
okuldan alınan, 10 yaşında şiddet görüp
okuldan tekrar alınan, 24 yaşında
tutuklanan, 27 yaşında en büyük rakibi
bir kahramanken kendisi hiç önemsenmeyen,
37 yaşında hakkında
dava açılan iki ay yalnız başına hastanede
yatan, otuz sekiz yaşında Suriye’ye
gönderilen, 39 yaşında idam cezasına
çarptırılan Atatürk'ten söz ediyoruz.
42 yaşında ise genç
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti’ni kurdu.
Peki acaba onun heykeline
yapılmış bir saygısızlık,
bir urgan atmak ya da ona
pranga vurmak, onun değerini bizim
gözümüzde değiştirir mi?
Ya da böyle bir şey mümkün müdür?
Diye Birkaç kavram üzerinden
şimdi birkaç hikaye ile de bağlı,bir takım
anlatımlar gerçekleştireceğim size.
Atatürk gerçekten bakıldığında
olağanüstü bir cesaret timsali.
O kadar cesur bir karakterden
söz ediyoruz ki
bir başka büyük isim Dünya
tarihinde Mahatma Gandhi,
o ünlü sözü
hatırlarsınz : “Ben İngilizlerin Tanrı
olduğunu zannediyorum.” diyor,
ta ki Atatürk onları yenene kadar.
Bakın Türkiye tarihinde 16 tane
imparatorluk ya da devlet kurmuş
bu tarihte savaş hileleri çok meşhurdur.
Onun cesaretine delalet edecek çok
güzel bir anekdot anlatacağım.
Büyük Taarruz öncesi Atatürk Ankara'da
bir çay partisi veriyor.
Bu da o meşhur savaş hilelerinden biri,
çünkü hemen ertesi gün eski, Türk Savaşı
taktiklerinden biri kullanılacak ve Kurt
Kapanı denilen bir baskın
gerçekleştirilecek.
Baskın planlanırken kurmaylarından
pek çoğu itiraz ediyor.
Hatta bunlardan Yakup Şevki Paşa :
“Paşam bunu yapmayalım,
eğer bu harekat başarısız olursa sizi
de asarlar, bizi de asarlar” diyor.
Atatürk’ün buna da cevabı şu oluyor:
“Paşam siz dert etmeyin,
sorumluluğu ben alıyorum.
Eğer bu harekatta başarısız olursak
önce siz beni asarsınız.” diyor.
Şimdi böyle bir cesarete gerçekten bir
urgan atmak acaba mümkün müdür?
Bir sonuç verir mi?
Atatürk’ü anlayabilmek için
Napolyon’u bilmek.
Büyük Kartacalı hükümdar Hannibal bilmek.
Atatürk’ü anlamak için
Timurlenk´i bilmek, Sezar’ı bilmek,
Hazreti Muhammed’i bilmek gerekir.
Bakın bu tarafı hiç konuşulmaz,
ama Atatürk hakkında yazılan
hatıralarında pek çoğunda Hazreti
Muhammed´e olağanüstü atıf vardır.
Atatürk, Hazreti Muhammed´i sadece bir
manevi önder olarak, bir peygamber olarak
görmez, aynı zamanda büyük bir
devrimci olarak görür
ve bunu defalarca da tekrarlamıştır.
Bedir Savaşı'nı tarihteki en
büyük zafer olarak görür.
Böyle bir stratejik ve taktik deha
asla bir daha tekrarlanmaz der.
Hatta Hazreti Muhammed’in büyük bir
devrimci olarak cahil ve kötücül bir
toplumdan bir devlet yaratma ülküsünü
kendisine amaç edinmiştir.
Bu kısmından hiç bahsetmeyiz mesela.
Hatta eğer siyasi kanadı böyle içe
ayırırsak, her iki taraf da enteresan bir
şekilde bahsetmez.
Atatürk hakkında bildiğimizi düşündüğümüz
şeylerin çoğu ya eksiktir, ya fazladır,
ya da ona ait değildir.
Enteresan bir şekilde sözünü
ettiğim şey o.
Atatürk pedagojisi de büyük hatalar
yapıyoruz ve çocuklara ve gençlere
özellikle en çok umuda ihtiyacımız
olduğu zamanda bence çok büyük
haksızlık yapıyoruz.
Atatürk bunun yanında tarih bilinci
çok yüksek bir isim.
Tarihi adeta bir geçmiş
bilimi olarak değil, gelecek bilimi
olarak algılayan bir isimden
söz ediyoruz aslında
Hariri kafasında Hariri´ye dikkat edin,
tarihi yeniden yorumlayarak,
dünya entelijansiyasının neredeyse
en tepesine çıktı
Atatürk´teki tarih bilinci eğer bizim
Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı politikasında
yıllardır uygulansa, yani savaşları sadece
tarihi tarihlerden ibaret değil de
tarih bilincine oturup anlayabilsek
geleceği kurma yönünde çok daha fazla
şanslı olacaktık.
Atatürk kendisini mesela biraz önce sözünü
ettiğim büyük Kartacalı hükümdar
Hannibal’in devamcısı
olarak kabul eder.
Çünkü Hannibal özelliği nedir?
Emperyalizme karşı ilk büyük savaşı
gerçekleştirmiş komutandır.
Her ne kadar başarısız olsa bile Roma’yı,
Büyük Roma’yı yıllarca titreten bu
komutan, Alp dağlarını 36 tane fille,
dağlardan aşağı doğru filleri indirerek
baskınla mesela Alp dağlarını geçmiştir.
Şimdi Atatürk'ün cesaretinden söz ettim.
Hannibal Alp dağlarını geçecek, dağlardan,
fillerle aşağı inecek de Anadolu
dağlarından Türk süvarileri
bu baskını yapamayacak mı?
Hem oradan feyiz alıp hem de aynı zamanda
tarihi bir bilinçle okuyan bu karakter,
aynı zamanda Kurtuluş Savaşının en
çetrefilli dönemlerinde Hannibal'in
Gebze’deki mezarının
bulunmasını vasiyet eder.
Hatta mezar bulundu mu?
Bulunmadı mı? soru işaretidir
ama onun vasiyetine ilişkin 1981 yılında
bugün Gebze’deki TÜBİTAK kampüsü
içerisinde bir Hannibal heykeli
bulunur, anıtı bulunur.
Sadece bu da değil, mesele çok alakasız
gibi görünse bile Atatürk
büyük Truvalı hükümdar Hektor hayranıdır,
Hektor’a defalarca referans verir.
Bunun aynısını kimde görürüz arkadaşlar?
Fatih Sultan Mehmet´te görürüz.
Bir başka büyük komutan,
Mora seferinden dönerken,
Atina´da Akropolis´in üzerine çıkıp:
“Truva senin intikamını
Greek’lerden aldım”
diyebilecek kadar tarih bilincine sahip,
bir başka komutan.
Fatih Sultan Mehmet’i Atatürk’ten,
Atatürk’ü Fatih Sultan Mehmet’ten ayırmak
gibi bir şey mümkün değildir.
Bunlar eşitliğin iki ucu gibidir
diye düşünebilirsiniz,
Ancak bunu bütüncül kavradığımız zaman
tarih bilincini yerli yerine oturtabiliriz
Atatürk aynı zamanda büyük
bir halk insanıdır.
Halkın hep içindedir.
Kimsenin olmadığı kadar halkın içindedir.
Ahmet Hidayet reel anlatır.
1924 Erzurum ve Pasinler depreminde,
sahayı dolaşıyorken
hatta bir reklam filmi vardır
biraz o filmin canlandırmasıdır o sahnenin
Gerçekten izbe, yıkılmış,
köylerin arasında perişan duran bir
köylünün yanına gider.
Köylüye sorar Baba der.
Depremde kaybın büyük mü?
Adam konuşmakta biraz çekinir.
Çekindiğini görünce daha yumuşak bir ses
tonuyla hükümetinden istediğin bir şey
var mıdır? Yapabileceğimiz
bir şey var mıdır? der
Adam böyle Kürt şivesiyle yarım yamalak,
ufak kısık bir sesle:
“Valla padişah bilir.” der.
Bunun üzerine Atatürk güler ve
der ki: “Baba artık padişah yok.
Siz onu kaldırmadınız mı? Sen söyle
devletinden istediğin bir şey var mı?”
Diye sorar.
Adam Valla padişah bilir lafını
tekrarladıktan sonra
sağında duran kaymakama döner ve der ki:
“Kaymakam devrimi yayamamışsınız.“ Der.
Bunun üzerine görevini yapmış edasıyla
ağırbaşlı bir şekilde Atatürk´e dönüp
konuşan genç tahrirat memuru der ki paşam
der, genelgeyi bütün köylere yolladık der.
Bunun üzerine Atatürk'ün suratı yüzü
fırtınaya tutulur ve şunu söyler
oğlum der, devrim genelgeyle olmaz,
devrim inanmakla olur.
O zaman sorarım.
Bu kadar inanmış bir zihnin ve onun
takipçilerinin acaba zihnine pranga
vurmak ya da heykeline urgan atmak
acaba mümkün müdür?
Diye sorduğunda cevabını
hepimiz biliyoruz.
O anlatılacak o kadar çok anekdot vardır
ki, on yıllardır laiklik nedir meselesini
çözememişizdir.
Bunu da Kılıç Ali Paşa anlatır.
Kılıç Ali’nin muhteşem bir anekdotudur
Bir gün meclisin çok tartışmalı ortamında,
zamanın din ulemalarından biri
mecliste kürsüye çıkar ve alaycı
bir tavırla bir konuşma yapar.
Konuşmanın özünde kabaca şöyle söyler:
“Ya sürekli laiklik, laiklik, laiklik
diyorsunuz da ne menem şeydir bu?
Laiklikle anlatın da bunu bilelim.”
diye tüm meclisle alay eder.
Riyaset makamında olan oturan Mustafa
Kemal dayanamaz, hocaya doğru döner.
Hoca der
çok basit anlamak mümkün.
Ben sana şöyle anlatayım,
Laiklik adam olmaktır der.
Gerçekten muhteşem bir anekdot.
Ben laikliğin bu kadar güzel
anlatıldığını hiç görmedim.
Atatürk aynı zamanda
tarih bilincinin, yüksek derinlikli
o entellektüel zekasının yanında
her daim minimal düşünebilen,
zarif düşünebilen de bir adamdı
ve adeta çağları aşan bir
fütürist aynı zamanda
eğer Atatürk’e fütürist demek
bir yanılgı olmaz.
Çünkü Atatürk’e ilişkin anlattığımız
anekdotlara bakıldığında, aslında bugün
çokça konuştuğumuz, yetişkin eğitimlerinde
pek söz konusu ettiğimiz
işte psikolojik dirençlilik,
çevik ve esnek zeka,
motivasyon, sürdürülebilirlik, karar
bilimi, strateji gibi laflar, disiplinler
o disiplininlerin her birine ilişkin
bir Atatürk anekdotu bulmak mümkündür.
Peki dip toplamda tam olarak
ne olmaktadır ki?
Bu kadar açık bir durum varken?
Yani her bir Türk ferdinin Atatürk'e bu
ülkede, çünkü Atatürk'ün cumhuriyetinde
yaşıyoruz ve ilelebet öyle yaşayacağız.
Umudumuz ve hayalimiz ve beklentimiz,
inandığımız şey bu.
Atatürk'ün bu kadar tartışma konusu olması
gerçekten anlaşılır olmaktan çok
uzak, ancak kötücül bir zihnin ürünüdür.
Atatürk bir siyasi görüş değildir.
Atatürk siyasetin kendisi de değildir.
Atatürk, siyasetin ve siyasetin kendisinin
getirdiği bütün o dip çevre
alanların üstünde bir karakterdir.
Kendisi de bu durumu defalarca ifade eder.
Tanrıöver´in, Süphi Tanrıöver´in
çok güzel bir açıklaması vardır.
Atatürk´e ilişkin
Kendi ağzından naklettiği
bir anekdottur bu.
Bence günümüzü de aydınlatan bir anekdot.
Atatürk der ki “İki tane Atatürk vardır.
Bir tanesi benim et ve kan olan Atatürk.
Bunu unutun.
İkinci Atatürk ise ben olarak ifade
edemeyeceğim bir Atatürk.
O biziz, o sizsiniz.
Anadolu'nun her köşesinde gelişme,
aydınlık ve çağdaş muasır medeniyetler
seviyesine ulaşma arzusuyla tutuşan bu
yolda benimle yola çıkan ve çıktıkları
yolda beni, aşmalarını mutlaka
elzem gördüğüm Atatürk.
Asıl Atatürk budur.
Onu anladığınız ve onu duyumsadığınız
sürece Cumhuriyet ilelebet payidar
olacaktır” notu ile aslında geleceğe
ilişkin çok önemli bir vurgu yapar.
O yüzden şaşırıyorum.
Beyin bilim çalışıyorum biliyorsunuz.
Beyin bilimde çokça sözünü ettiğimiz
bir laf vardır, insanlar sonsuz derecede
karmaşık ve ilginçtir ama çıktıları son
derece iptidai olabilir deriz biz.
Ben diyorum ki vücutta iki tane iki loblu
organ var, bir tanesi beyin, sol
beyin, sağ beyin, diğer iki loblu organın
üzerinde oturuyorsunuz şu an.
Nedense zaman zaman beyni kullanmaktansa
diğer lob ile düşünme eğiliminde oluyoruz.
Bence bir çok şeyin sebebi bu.
Hatta bir insanda minimum beş tane duyu,
organı varken, her şeyi tümden anlama
konusunda da gerçekten çok manevi.
Bu da bir önceki sözün tamamlayıcısı
olarak kabul edin ama yılmak yok ama
yılmak yok.
Bütün bu menhus olaylarda her defasında
bir kez daha görüyoruz ki aslında bu
Cumhuriyet Atatürk'ün cesaretine,
Atatürk'ün ferasetine, Atatürk'ün
ilerleme arzusuna, Atatürk’ün psikolojik
dirençliliğine, Atatürk’ün çevik ve esnek
zihnine sahip bir cumhuriyet.
O yüzden bütün bu değerleri, bunlar
bizim yumuşak güç unsurlarımız.
Birbirinden ayrılmadan,
birbirinden ayırmadan,
geleceğe koşturmak bizim görevimiz.
Ben canı gönülden ve kalpten bunun
olabileceğine inanıyorum ve her daim
Atatürk'le birlikte kalın diyorum.